it
- Angela
but I shan't
by any so high level fame the power
what then
sisters indifference hope you guys are
doing well welcome to my channel sister
you need video actually because on this
video we have sister Fatima she's
working on a documentary and also
mashallah up in the working as a family
this is the far tomorrow the sister who
doesn't kind of work and her brother
Abdullah who a competent accompanies her
what she's doing this so there are
lovely nice family mashallah me on a
blessing for Barack in the work they're
doing and there's a question that
assists over at the Oscars gonna ask me
that question she's here and she's not
gonna be on camera she's gonna be off
camera asking me and we're gonna deal
with a situation I'm sorry I said a lot
of questions I love sisters who wear the
hijab but those who don't wear it so
this night a car was coming past and I
was walking to down the road and we're
going opposite directions and in the
father the driver slowed down and then
looked he had a hoodie on and everything
I just thought maybe he thought he knew
me and whatever couple minutes later as
I was crossing the devil cross in the
car reverse back the same car the man
removed his head and he's calling me
back at Kosair okay so when I although I
like behind to see who it was like his
calling there's only me so I approached
like the window from far like yeah how
can I help you the question was how old
are you know excuse me and it was like
holiday and I said I'm probably older
than you anyway and I said I have to go
and he said no no no I'm 27 Hardy and I
was like I'm sorry [ __ ] up but as as
you turn out there's a second zipper
across there just were the police
station is so he stopped there ehman was
across the street I was crossing the
street from there then he stopped okay
and then he stopped the second time and
he said phone number phone number
yes it's doing that phone number phone
number
I was like no and then I walked off I
was really annoyed as a Muslim girl yeah
I was like what makes a non-muslim man
have the strength and the ability to ask
me for my number if I haven't provoked
in every evil in any way I haven't
spoken to her I haven't done anything so
the question that you're probably asking
is okay I'm wearing the hijab you know
I'm not dressed up in a certain way so
why yeah that's a question yeah hey job
is supposed to be a barrier okay let me
tell you why I might be right
why men especially not losing men are
going down this route now maybe in
general we have a psychology yeah if
you're a practice if you don't feel
responsible especially we have a
psychology where we are weak and our
biggest weakness is woman yeah my
teacher always said to me three fingers
German money fame oh yeah
now this doesn't mean women are equal it
just means that we have a weakness
towards them just as a woman has a
weakness towards it she's gonna secure
you know makeup or bags or so with a man
the biggest weakness we are told offices
around the business you know weakness
for a man it's a woman you know and the
Postal Service said there is nothing
more I fear for my own more than woman
yeah so this means that we have that
weakness so with men in general when you
have no integrity you do something
nothing they're just like a junkie yeah
is that we when I say we are not meant
to ya know we try our luck with anything
just travel yeah so now before there was
a parent before the hijab meant
something before the hijab was that okay
you know there are respectful you don't
do that
I think there's something that's
happened at schools people both Muslim
and non-muslim to say you know what that
don't mean nothing anymore
what does cause that that's really
crucial for us to understand and I
personally believe that disclosure both
both males as well
yeah so you see if I imagine
no soul sisters and the standard don't
feel attacked I wear a full let's say I
have a puppy a lot miss walk in my hand
I've got a long beard and I've got to
standing I'm seeing a stomach words the
army I'm doing you know I'm going as
righteous flicks now when you see
brothers going and if they see me
flirting with girls
hugging girls mess around with girls
what's going to happen is that that's
value of that clothing and the
appearance that I look I'm causing
damage to it now I'm damaging it slowly
yeah so now there's damage because so
then what's gonna happen is non-muslim a
woman who look at me not that I you know
who's righteous it looks holy you know
respect you have when they start to see
me doing certain acts they're gonna be
like okay maybe one off then they turn
around and see another guy in a for
doing the same thing then they walk and
they go and they see another guy making
stories that it's you know no way they
do that yeah so not enough like wow okay
might be one or ever
when this occurrence keeps happening and
when they see this guy who I don't know
maybe plastic eyebrows or I don't know
just looks a certain way you know as
this in his eye I don't know but I'm
safe
you're damaging the uniform that you
wear the uniform who presents something
yeah when a house is burning me to see a
firefighter you are gonna call him why
because his dress
symbolizes something now imagine this if
you have suspend any constant fireman
please get him hostas better let it go
sorry sir just because I'm dressed up in
this uniform does it make me a
firefighter that's like somebody coming
and saying just because I'm dressed like
this doesn't mean I'm holy nobody's
expecting you to be holy but they're
surfing that you don't do you get it
nobody seen me an angel we're all
sinners but seeing a society job or a
brother in a beard kissing in public
that's wrong you know like come on I
have limits you know saying so doing
certain apps that I don't know drinking
alcohol come on you don't do that do you
get it just the way you see a police
officer who's there's protective
certainly doing the opposite you're like
doesn't fit into your uniform you're not
supposed to be doing that you get antsy
so that's what I believe
once that's happening it's damaged the
whole principle and the whole value of
the hijab so what happens now is that
Muslim men and one Muslim men when they
had the psychology of okay let me try my
luck so they go and they try so let's
see let's see with you like mashallah
men of less you know about that
you don't saying you just say look get
lost but if there's sister where there
seems sister in a job and be Maccabi be
there might be a bit like Oh Kevin come
here
trust me something to even try that I'm
losing many a day my I've heard of this
then when they see sisters dressed up in
a certain way she's not to blame for the
way she's dressed but the fact is that
he judged she's wearing a head has no
value no value is good why is it one
what's causing it it's because it's
other one comment it's become you must
know oh it's too for example there's a
lot of theories now this is something
like a discussion I have of my friends
become sexualized a little bit because
of the way some girls will wear hijab
but really skimpy out there or some
girls would would do certain things and
I'm not blaming girls only right I'm
saying men are no longer seen a cadavers
a barrier anymore they see everything
else that woman wears it before it was
like the moment a girl has a joke
whether she was wearing tight or loose
complete like no no yeah
where is now even Muslim men or non
Muslim men try that off oh no it's so
many numbers the men approach just like
you know because what it is now you need
to understand who's menu is none was the
woman you know certain woman maybe none
was a little wealthy job but also this
is to struggle Israel so what it is is
they look and and sadly today society
women are you know you need to dress it
away look at now that's become boring
nothing
you know yeah yes well that's what's let
me don't cover up now your men are
almost like in the girls that come right
now yes exactly
you know why because nobody else will
become so in a way the way they dress
and they behave that now manager stuff
latest and I'm bored you get I want
something more challenging so that can
be one factor that's the metaphor well
another thing is that I said to you
before is that damage that's being
happened so when he approaches that girl
in a hijab however she's dressed and she
starts smoking they're smiling he's
thinking look I just tried my luck when
he worked so now when that happens do
you think he's gonna be next time you
see the hijab is gonna be like nah no
he's gonna see she's probably gonna be
on it the way the other girl was so now
this comes to our point of what brothers
and sisters who observe this that make
even this beard was I might leave him at
this but the fact that I look like a
Muslim I need to observe that a job do
you ever try to say modesty so when we
tarnish that you're not only just
damaging yourself you know just we need
to understand you are damaging Islam
yeah you know the whole concept of it
and you're making people not respect it
you can see so that's why it's so
important on us that we keep this and
this principle understand that you when
you do these actions it's not just you
you're effective everyone and you're
taking all those sisters and all those
problems and Robert will do it as well
you're taking them all down with you
you're taking them all down with you and
those who are genuine but not about that
life
yes it's a good responsibility but all
were saying is look you're not gonna be
perfect no one's asking you to be
perfect you're gonna have your struggles
I'm not having a versus a to wear the
hijab and have jeans look you know I
feel strong it's a struggle me I have
struggles you get it what I'm just
saying is there's certain things that
you shouldn't do even if you were in a
job and tydomin there's certain things
we should not do you're gonna try to see
cuz then you have reason like you have
sister saying I don't where they jump I
don't do what these job kills do look
that's wrong as well exactly
that's wrong team that's why I would see
why
this is what and you guys are watching
it's a keeping with the reason comments
on section below
yeah if there's any other question that
you wanna ask me via sister [ __ ] this
have a vote you ever stop and ask Annie
no probably a cold-ass got it no problem
you can basically sisters if there's
question that you lack sister Fatima to
ask me or even Robert no problem just
ask Isis possible say look this is we
have a question they're not really can
be serious
nothing society it's change yes oh yeah
as well say